welcome to this video playing famous
last words funny name from from Germany
okay should I play this b6 okay let's
let's do this english defence there is
no name and it's a brand new account we
check this okay very new account also
have never played in them ok so this eve
or c4 setup is a pretty good pretty good
term on way to play against um v6 Bishop
e7 white normally goes for g3 here d 3
or 92 yeah 92 was actually what i like
most d3 it's of course a playable move
no question but it looks a bit passive
so how to proceed the most Bishop before
is losing a bit and strength IAM simply
because um you will play 9283 and gain
the bishop pair without having any
direct problems i know that in in some
games i played Bishop c5 p.m. sort of
trying to provoke provoke um deform
hmm how bad is this really ship c5 can I
can I do something like that it's a bit
cheeky this move okay let's let's try
that well this is this whole I'm hold
opening c4b 6 is a bit of them and time
anti see for opening because it in a way
drags White's players the white players
out of their comfort zone there is
really a sort of breed of c-4 players
who really do c4e for g3 all the time
and with this b6 they and you to adjust
a bit and play differently so on I'd
like to play a little bit yeah
unconventional against against this
opening trying to force them to do
things that they normally don't do okay
you just went Knight f3 mmm can I go
nighty 7 + f5 one problem could be the
move a 3 of course
Wow yeah well okay when when i was
playing Bishop c5 I knew that this is a
bit a bit fishy King a three hour
probably playing 96 and drop the bishop
back in case of an attack d for there is
still Bishop b4 which looks let's think
okay the night is some going to to e7 to
play f5
I just got a chest chat message that he
is watching the channel or thanks let's
let's see what he's doing though there
are many many possible things so I can
also just play we should be too and
castles but there should be two I will
play a 5 i'm in the sun hmm interesting
question is there if he goes a three
okay something entirely different
hmm okay
so make that doesn't make some sense to
play I'm sorry to play an age 60
yeah i think i should i can do that it's
not hurting me in any way taking on e
seven looks totally harmless probably is
going to h form on not maybe a positive
effect of Bishop g5 is of course that it
makes f5 a bit more difficult to play
can I go night see 694 maybe of course
you can play deform it should be four
very tough that happens to you if you
try to play unconventional openings at
least it happens to me need to really
early on solve some problems
yeah defo bishop before it's certainly
somewhat better provide not sure how
much better but it's it's it's better
for white okay so he's not doing
anything special about 94 okay okay I
guess I'll do that trying to make some
use of this bishop on c5 it opens up the
long diagonal here but just of course at
the moment nothing to write home about
just before protected by d3 but yeah
maybe a five at some point will breathe
some life into this bishop
you can take plane I to be five but I
can just take me to I believe rupee one
Bishop f6 and there is nothing special
going on okay so who does you want to
play before I can I think I can play
castles anyway so I'll do that my next
move will be at five if there's nothing
special happening before I take a three
play Bishop tea for this should be
really ok
okay so f5 yeah nightie for something I
can always take f3 and play Bishop
before so I think I'm this this is
really a playable position now I mean
before him playable it was but probably
not very comfortable maybe just deform
provide earlier I think this was good
form a little bit of an edge maybe more
i'm not sure why do I to a certainty
better to deform
yeah what should he do now I mean it can
take a five but I will check with the
look i believe suddenly getting really a
burst of activity yeah taking with the
rook i guess i can also consider to take
on e to first whatever that's not
looking great on you yeah route takes I
guess should be am should be okay for me
you have the only thing that's a bit um
a bit annoying is this pin Bishop on
edge for the spin okay
yeah the spinner I was thinking that
create might help it might help it my to
help to to address this issue
yeah well I'm really threatening now to
take see three teky form winning a pawn
and destroying white structure it's not
so easy to learn to avoid really let's
say Bishop f3a still take on c 3 t go
Nev hi this is just a very very nice
structure for black with this double
pawns on the C file and the possibility
to set up my corns on dark squares
blockading white completely don't know
what you should do will not be five I
can take me too well there should be 2
rupee one Bishop f6 and I just I'm just
torn up yeah this is this is probably
that the best way to play okay so just
to rook takes I guess
yeah I cannot really go back right to f8
then or is there yeah probably you're an
interesting moment now I can I can play
a bishop f6 sound trying to exchange now
that's a very lame move Willie I'd like
to play Queen yet really but might be
five or so might be five is not easy to
counter
hmm
that's very tricky but Queenie 8 is
really so nice Queenie 802 claimed 95 96
but this night be five more I wonder if
I should really ever maybe should
investor who will move like a six to
prevent night be five so that i can play
Queen yet I don't think why does any
direct threat or anything okay I'll do
that let's go asics prevent 95 Bishop
takes e6 I think it's just not working
no no it is not working
95 that move looks looks a bit crazy but
hmm
95 might be crazy but what what am I
actually doing against it 95 85 Bishop
e7 it's a bit not great 95 it's not easy
95 maybe I could have played 90 x g5 to
the Queen sack Bishop the 89 f for this
once I think possible really okay well
nevermind it's not it's not happening
and now queen here I am the whole idea
of the of it all and now my idea is to
play night at five or 96 maybe green g6
also also a possibility
cool this I didn't see at all now while
g6 looks like told you're rubbish but I
can I can move the Queen back to d8
night let's not great
how how bad is it actually g6 I mean g6
Bishop is seven hmm there should be
seven Queenie seven Bishop cheese 625
hmm nobody should be four at the end
Jeff
g6 Bishop e7 queen is seven Bishop g6
hard to believe but
yeah he can play Bishop before really
looks it looks crazy I want this is not
the crazy that's the wrong word but
somehow I fail to accept that this is so
really happening we need let's play this
just play it back
let's see is he now playing form but
should avoid just what was it coming
from Bishop g4 right repeating or is he
doing something trying to win
ok it's not repeating
hmm
that's not very nice not at all this pin
is super annoying yeah can i play g5 at
probably totally crazy but maybe g5 it's
possible we should be 39 f 5 hmm alright
come on if it's not working it's got a
nice sculpt I only need to get rid of
this there should be three right at five
I don't think that this should be too
bad with this active night on f5 the
bishop on deform where Queen g4 is not
possible with Luke Air Force winning not
sure if we can play something like 95 95
hd5 Bishop g5 to should have 6mm don't
think that this should win for white I
have still some pieces around the king
should be shouldn't be so terrible
Bishop d3 I think don't I don't really
see a way no I don't believe that really
maybe maybe it's okay maybe it is but
it's it would be it would surprise me if
it's really objectively good now let's
just briefly consider if there's
something else don't think so the main
problem is between g4 it's like looking
like the normal muth I'll take it play
King age seven then I'm threatening rook
g8 myself and he's not quickly bringing
a rook or some some support maybe
chat you'll do that anyway though now
here and yeah the thing is like let's
say tweenage for there's night f5 this
immediately stops the attack and here
what else is there yeah neither five is
is stopping all the tech push-up g6 is a
double check but I can also just I can
just take it Queen h3 there's Queen edge
form now it's simply not enough
attacking power just the the lone Queen
enter and the bishop voltar won't turn
to do the trick
I think after g5 he really just needs to
go to g3 play this position it's
probably not not bad for white at all
and clear I don't know ya hear what
white is forced to trade Queens young
and dumb yeah here I can go rook g8 well
book g8 Bishop g4 92 as a nice load shot
and look him increasing increasing the
pressure
we have the night is heading towards to
form I guess 30 40 maybe prepare okay
Jade
check yeah winning out for now but this
was already beyond saving of course
check check check in with the king as
always lies there are made somewhere
maybe like that look g4 and rook f5
something like that I don't see a maid
Jack and give the check here first white
forfeits on time now I I don't see a
direct maids probably the comp doesn't
see one as well okay it it looks a bit
like him like a mate coming but probably
not yeah we need to check this position
I mean okay the stuff before you can
also analyze but I'd like to quickly
check here when I played Knight to c6 is
very big drawback yeah well this I
thought 34 and now normal move Bishop d3
Roxy one something like that maybe or d5
even d5 is given by the computer I like
this better no question I mean this was
a very creative try bye-bye me button
bd4 is better for white yeah now i get
to get this in which is helping me
making some use of all that no f5 this
is starting to look quite good and here
the computer just wants to recapture
with the pawn yeah probably also because
there is this g5 idea winning this piece
maybe look at let's look at this now a
six actually given by the computer
interesting okay well I thought that
this is the kind of simple solution but
okay well a six rupee one Queen e8
interesting and now this yeah I didn't
see Bishop h5 whole g6 really yeah just
do that and there is there is nothing
great happening here for me computer
gives the roof form with equal that's
interesting equal gives that as equal
they are maybe I mean I'm quite quite
active him but probably not better
for me or anything okay I went back
because i didn't really couldn't I
couldn't make g6 work ok nitey for
instead of repeating yeah g5 film the
computer also just gives Bishop g3 and
gives like a slight edge interesting
yeah this is what I was thinking
probably getting the g3 bishop yeah it's
a very unusual position but there are
simply some things that are working in
blacks favor those two bishops are
really excellent it's long diagonal and
this is on divorce just a great piece
and there is no really really mating
attack or anything against the king it's
it's open but you cannot play h4 or the
F porn it's not not like easy and this
is I think just not working Bishop age 6
stronger maybe trapping this but look
and look at something like that the
remaining pieces that I have are
excellent night here Bishop here night
to h4 queen here this the the minor
pieces are much better than the rooks at
the moment yeah this was check even
easier because he cannot really bring
any of the rooks and just the Queen and
the bishop are not a good attacking
tandem here I'm just playing nine f5 or
rock g8 what according a depending on
what he's playing it here well after
Queen straight there it's it just just
over yeah probably am around here one
can try to look for improvements
yeah obviously white can can retreat and
repeat the position I mean this is of
course possible doing something else
here this say here here another move I
don't know this is one computer
suggestion not a very natural move it
sort of looks a bit strange for this
bishop but I don't have anything c5 is
the recommended response which is fairly
logical this was hanging and while you
can retreat to f6 but c5 is just more
ambitious yeah I don't know it's it
looks like a playable position for form
for both sides it's just complicated
okay interesting game thanks for
watching